when you expand the first Karen
binomials what do you get you get a
squared minus B squared right the
difference of two squares if you're
really sharp today you might also
recognize the second one what's the
second one if it's the difference not of
squares the different reviews yeah um
you might be able to predict based on
the type that I'm trying to establish
and you should be able to also verify by
expanding it out what you do this guy
you get a whole bunch of you into the
cancel and all you're left with is a to
the for take away the to the fall
okay come just report we leave this
result I want to point out number one
the way that it grows with the way that
it grows these guys same shape but this
thing get won't vary longer and longer
right to try and match up to these two I
letting the girls longer and longer
longer here is in here is the here q me
for a second what's the power here and
how many turns out of here yeah if it is
a binomial right so what's the time here
and how many turns this yup one more
time power number test oh good keep that
the back in one now at the beginning of
this double lesson I introduce you to a
different way of writing the definition
of best principles without H's without
agent instead and I'm going to show you
two redstone because I was walking
around some of you did you damn it I'm
going to point out again if I think
about it set of H's an X and a see
another coordinate that is you by okay
and I can write the derivative the grade
function adds the limit as C gets closer
to X do you see it's the same idea right
H getting closer to zero
is the famous see sort of climbing down
to get to X the limit as C approaches X
what's the ride is fun have a look at
the rice is that if this distance is it
then which is the difference between FS
a and f of X so that's my new grams
what's my denominator yeah it's just x2
minus x1 which is just C take away X
that is the right okay now the reason
why I'm drawing attention to this is
because it is particularly useful to
prove a more efficient way of going
about all of this differentiating that
you've been doing okay now please don't
get me wrong first principle is
important in fact we're going to return
to first principles again and again
every time we learn to differentiate a
new kind of thing so you cannot leave
this behind you must understand it but
it's slow as but it would be great if we
had a more efficient way so what I want
to do is consider at the moment
everything we've been dealing with had
read powers of X ok so if you wanna put
a little subheading under this it's
differentiating powers of X I mean like
x squared and X cubes the next to the 4
and all that kind of thing so it
generically speaking every power of X is
X to the power of some number right so
if I want to differentiate is my
differential operator right X to the
power of some tombow okay and we're ends
give me like if I'm ok then I'm going to
appeal to the first principle but I'm
going to do it this way we do it this
way and you will see why this way of
setting it out even though if points in
the same reality rise over run is going
to be a little more useful to in this
case can someone help me work out I'll
do you write limit as C approaches X for
this particular function what is going
to be inside the limit
new matter any takers what is f of C in
this case if this is f of X F of C F of
the sink means everywhere you saw an X
before you're going to substitute in C
so instead of X to the power of n it's
going to be C to the power of n right
same thing with this guy except that's
just f of X by definition and then on
the denominator you get this guy how are
you feeling so far you're right all I've
done is just a bit of substitution now
this point here remember how we look the
difference of squares and difference of
cubes and then difference of whatever
you call these things okay you can see
that's kind of what's happening here
right the difference between two powers
and the powers are the same okay
now I'm not going to do a Phase II proof
for you but it's not that hard to guess
that if I had a to the N take away B to
the N we'll have a look at the pattern
what do you think about you with it's
probably going to be a minus B right
okay what's going to follow have a look
carefully look at these numbers and look
at how they relate to these numbers this
is one power less than it has to be
because it's going to multiply by this
guy is that make sense so how do I write
that it's going to be a move on one less
so this will be a to the inverse one
when you go to the right what happens to
the a terms what happens there powers
may get smaller we notice your binomial
theorem right what about the powers of
beat what happens of entries they get
bigger so the next one will be a to that
and - sook is getting smaller
and then there'll be a B the next one
will be a to the N minus 3 is still
getting smaller how many bees will be
having will they be now there will be
there will be two
there is no BT there's one be here fit
to me that you're Greek what will the
very last turn be Peter the the air -
one right there's always one less
because it's going to multiply by this
guy when it's all expands out B to the N
minus one okay so what that looks like
in this case well this is the limit as C
approaches X of what have a look the
first is easy to run it's just a small
bracket the a by this B in this case
will be C by this X R now you see why I
wrote it like this because I cannot
evaluate the limit here while this
denominator is there because the
denominator with zero is CNX are the
same thing do you agree with that but
now that I've got this on the numerator
I can do some category which is what
we've been doing all the limits you've
had so far
what will they end up with on the
right-hand side instead over instead of
C's I'll have X's sorry instead of a
that I've seized and instead of Bees
I'll have exits do you agree so what's
that going to look like I guess there
will be C to the N minus 1 and then the
C's climb down in power don't they so
this will be seeded up n minus 2 and how
many X's one of them right there X is
none of these then they're receiving to
keep climbing down so this is C the
power of n minus 3 and how many X's are
there there are climbing up and then
I'll establish the pattern got what was
a very large term in X to the N minus 1
just like my B to the N minus 1 are you
okay with me so far this is a lot of
terms of staying with me the pattern is
just like we've been dealing with the
binomial theorem so shouldn't be too
dangerous for us okay now the point of e
factorize you display is because cool
I've got a Siemens and on the top and so
you might have sex with a bonus and they
can both go what did I leave you
here we go now this is the brilliant
part I love this brush this okay I have
rearranged and fast drives in this way
so that I no longer have to see minus X
or the denominator now that that's the
case I can actually evaluate this thing
I can actually happen when to sing I can
actually work out what happens when C
does turn into X what's this thing
become will see is going to turn into an
axe right so it's going to be this do
you agree what about this what's this
going to do this will be X to the N
minus 2 X to the N minus 2 times X to
the 1 right and then this C will become
water or all the things are turning into
X do you agree so this is X minus three
x squared da to the thought that guy has
no C terms in it so just a slave okay
now come back come back go back
different two squares how many times
difference of cubes how many times
difference of powers of for how many
terms so I'm doing difference of these
things so how many terms of it there are
n of them
so what have we just established what
are you just established that if you
have a power of it empower you like then
all you have to do is have a look let's
try this out with this guy because this
was the first one we did right
there's a power there I'm choosing N
equals three so my derivative my
gradient function will be write that
power as the number up front and then
what do you do to power it goes out by
one do you see that like so which of
course is 2x which we got before right
yeah there are other results we've seen
which amazingly this also works with do
you remember we did this at the start of
the double before you got your papers
back you can write this in a power of X
what's the power of X minus one right so
I'm going to give it a go with this this
is amazing because N equals minus one
shouldn't work where this extension it
should have worked this is somewhat a
really nice things when it just works
anywhere what's going to happen that's
where in like so I'm going to write an X
to that n minus 1 which is minus 2 which
is exactly what you found like this
principles one more or the other ones
you operative this lesson root of x
squared that's like well the square root
of x is also a power of X what power so
I'm going to write an X to the N minus 1
just watch out for this one note here's
the end here's the X what's the N minus
1 just watch out it's negative 1/2 so
that means it's going to be on the
denominator
cuz it's negative and it's going to be a
square root because it's to the power of
1/2 which is exactly what you've got